Thanksgiving as I said just around the
corner so I thought I'd invite a friend
to teach us how to decorate for the
holidays she's got her own
do-it-yourself YouTube channel she went
away for a year had some issues but
she's back now please welcome melody
crafts everybody
oh nice to see you again Nelly yeah so
what are we making today we're making a
classic hand turkey just trace your hand
cut it out and decorate it like this oh
wow that's adorable
really is adorable is right now I'm sure
people are thinking but melody I can't
make a hand turkey I don't have hands no
I don't really think many people are
thinking that but you can actually trace
any body part if you don't have hands
you can make a foot turkey oh okay all
right well that's that's fine and cute
yeah that's fine yeah and look I know a
lot of people don't have feet no that's
that's really not true so if you don't
have feet or hands you can always make a
sideboob turkey Wow okay
now if you're one of those people who
doesn't have hands or feet or a side
boob you can actually make a uvula
turkey oh ah ha ha ha or a thigh gap
turkey
or a small intestines Turkey I'm sorry
how do you how did you trace a person
small intestine and if you don't have
any of those you can always use
grandma's skull okay no don't do that
you want ads Mema's skull lying around
no they don't no they don't
melody cross everybody
[Applause]